how do you keep your head in the game
when one of your squad is killed
yeah you know
well i think for me you have to treat it
like
mission men in that order
and to me there's no use you know the
milk is on the floor
there's no use crying over it you know
eod doesn't
you know defuse a bomb that already went
off okay
what you got to do is try not to lose
any more your men
okay now you just got to do the mission
with the dead guy
and i know that sounds maybe cruel so
there ain't no time to sit there and
mourn
or do any of that you have to complete
your op you have to do your mission
right um
there's plenty of time to mourn there's
plenty of time to figure out what went
wrong
or what didn't go wrong or whatever
happened when you're back at the ops
done
and that's why we train like that when
we train and we're going through a
building
and they put a guy down you just step
over and clear the house because
you don't want to get you know more than
one killed you just have to do what
you've been trained to do
and in the leadership position it's very
hard not to
you know you can train all your life but
when something happens like that
it's very hard not to just go oh my god
i've got somebody killed you know what
happened what happened because i take it
very personally
because it was one of my guys and i
racked my brain for a long time
and then i figured out that
well you know i just got to do my job
and be a leader
you know and i can't let the rest of the
guys down i can't let myself down on my
team
my country so i got to do what i got to
do to get out of there and not get out
of there but complete the op
and then figure it out then take care of
him as best we can and have a lot of
respect
and that's about best way i can answer
that bro
yeah you know i i remember uh after mark
got killed
and he was obviously he was the first
seal killed in iraq he's the first guy
that ever worked for me that got killed
and
i remember a couple days went by we
actually did the memorial
ceremony um
in like a couple days went by and i was
kind of trying to figure out what to say
to the platoons specifically what to say
to your platoon
right and i was sort of uh
and i realized what i was doing right
what i was doing was
the only thing i knew how to do which is
work
yep and finally
i remember i was i wrote that's right
that's what i wrote down i'm like look
mark came into your platoon and and i
said
hey mark is the best [ __ ]
ever yeah he was and my [ __ ] soul is
crushed right now
and actually remember as i was talking
i started getting emotional and
i i stopped and i was getting a little
choked up
and i stopped talking i was just trying
to get it together
and you were sitting there and you're
like hey man
it's okay yep and i was like
check this is what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna work yep and this is what
we're gonna do
gonna work we're gonna work you know
when that happened
i was thinking about that
i i never ever once
shed one tear and i started getting like
concerned like do i have
anything my feelings at all
and then we came back from that
deployment i remember maybe
i don't know six months later or
something
it may not sound like it may shock you
but i used to like cats i used to like
cats you know
you always seem like a cat guy i like
dogs too you know
i just me and my girlfriend the time had
cats
and my cat died and i bawled like a
little baby for like three hours that
just
i think it was just appointing me
waiting for her to come out
you know i want to be like okay because
you're team guy around that stuff all
the time
people getting maimed shot killed and
blown up and
you know and then it kind of festers and
then i i think
you know it's kind of deep and stuff but
whatever i'm not really that deep of a
person
and it just came out and i was like you
know that's kind of cool yeah so maybe i
was just
you know i took the like be hard thing a
little too too
too much probably but